so hello and welcome to yet another
episode of biographics I'm your interim
host Carl smore and today we're talking
about Alfred Hitchcock the master of
suspense if anyone who's tuning in for
the first time and doesn't know all the
videos here on biographics are based on
scripts submitted To Us by a member of
our writing team and in this case that
is Ru Alexander you can follow on the
social media links below and while
you're down there you can like comment
subscribe we're doing it earlier in the
video than we normally would because
YouTube analytics say if I say those
three things early enough in the video
they're more likely to happen it sucks I
know let's get to
it give them pleasure the same pleasure
they have when they wake up from a
nightmare that's a quote from Alfred
Hitchcock and it immediately gives
people a little insight into his
approach to film making even if they've
never seen one of his movies before and
spoilers you've probably seen one of his
movies before and if you've not seen one
of his movies you've seen a parody of
one of his movies or a remake like if
you've watched The Simpsons you've seen
Alfred Hitchcock Hitchcock was the
so-called master of suspense the title
he clings to even now more than half a
century after his best words came out
his greatest movies are masterpieces
that perfectly blend Thrills mystery and
romance to create Timeless viewing
experiences there aren't many classic
directors whose filmography is still so
well regarded and popular in modern
times so today we're going to take a
look at the stunning career and the
Troublesome personal life of Alfred
Hitchcock and we start as we always do
at the
beginning
Alfred Joseph Hitchcock was born August
13th 1899 in London's leaton Stone
District the youngest of three children
of William Hitchcock and Emma Jane wheen
his father worked as a green grer like
his father before him and both his
parents were devout Catholics who
enforced a strict upbringing later in
life Hitchcock or hitch as his friends
would call him remembered his childhood
as lonely and somewhat sheltered not
really having any friends or mates as we
say in Britain growing up he partly
attributed this to his obesity which he
blamed on his mother who used food as a
remedy for most of his problems
meanwhile Alfred's father was something
of a disciplinarian and one story that
Hitchcock would recount multiple times
an adult was one occasion when he was 5
years old and his father sent him down
to the local police station with a note
asking the sergeant on duty to lock the
young Alfred in jail for a few minutes
to show him what happened to naughty
little boys and this sort of worked we
guess because hitchock developed a
severe fear of having anything to do
with the law and even as an adult he
wouldn't even drive a car out of fear he
would get a ticket the same education
continued at school with hitchrock
attended the St Ignatius college at
Jesuit Secondary School in Stanford Hill
where corporal punishment was the norm
whenever the pupils acted out of line
afterwards hitchock enrolled in ninth
class as a technical school where he
studied engineering and navigation his
father died in 1914 and with his older
siblings out of the house Alfred had to
get a day job during this time to
support himself and his mother he found
one with the Henley Telegraph and cable
company as a a technical Clerk and he
was too young to join World War I and
when he did come of age in 1917 he
received a C3 classification basically a
low grade in Fitness and he was excused
for military service so instead he
enlisted as in volunteer group of the
royal Engineers although initially
Hitchcock displayed interesting
engineering as the years went on he
quickly developed his artistic side
finding a talent for drawing as he
became a draftsman who made technical
plans and sketches he continued his
night studies this time focused on
illustrations and graphic design and
this kind of dedication did not go un
notice in his workplace Hitchcock was
promoted to Henley's advertising
Department we served as a jack of all
trades dogs body he wrote he edited for
the company's newspaper and magazine
advertisements he arranged their layout
and he drew the graphic illustrations
when he felt like it he further expanded
his artistic range by writing short
stories and articles and even drawing
caricatures for the company's new
in-house magazine the Henley which
started publishing in June 1919 and if
you really wanted to Hitchcock could
have probably just had a nice long safe
career at Henley he loved the job and
the company made it pretty clear he was
a very valued employee but still he
chafed and the more he leaned into his
artistic side the more he wanted to make
that his full-time job being there he
developed a strong passion for the new
exciting form of art called movie making
and would spend many an evening down his
local theater and then back home when he
would read all the latest trade
magazines then in 1920 he saw an
announcement that would change his life
forever famous players lasi the American
movie company that would later become
Paramount Pictures was going to open up
a new studio in London that will be my
golden ticket thought Hitchcock so that
same year he abandoned his safe cushy
job at Henley and embarked on a path to
become a Movie
Maker oh hi there U before we continue
with today's video about Alfred
Hitchcock let's take a word from our
sponsor skillshare and guys behind the
scenes because this is a team effort
here at biographics tell me more about
skillshare and why we're specifically
putting in this video well skillshare if
people are unaware is an online learning
community which has thousands of classes
and members yes what skillshare can
teach you is very relevant to today's
video topic I personally have a
fascination with uh Hitchcock and his
work I think that he was obviously a a
fascinating director and obv his films
arean he's considered one of the best
directors of all time the master of
suspense yes so when I found out that
this was going to be the video that we
were going to be putting the spot and I
actually had a look myself and
skillshare to see what kind of courses
could you do to be a bit more like
Hitchcock yes and I found one by an
author called Benjamin pery mhm which is
called writing suspense how to write
stories that thrill in any genre it
sounds like a very good course for
anybody who wants to learn how to write
specifically suspense just like
Hitchcock do they also have cooking
courses so you can get the physique of
um Hitchcock as well I imagine they
would also have cooking courses the
legendary hitch cocky and physique so
just so rotund such a round large man
the good thing about skillshare as well
is that the classes aren't just for
professionals or they're not just for
beginners there is a range for people
who want to learn all different areas
yes I think that's the key thing as well
because like there's always that weird
Middle Ground is it's like I I know the
basics I'm not a professional I'm
somewhere in the middle and there's
always wiggle room there to improve upon
the skills that you have just to make
things more efficient just to like or
even just rushing up the skills that you
already have you also come out the end
with a completed project that you can
share which is good are you enjoying
yourself I I love playing with my anunt
ETS it's very fun I've had a look at the
classes myself and being a creative
person as I like to call myself a
creative person there's so many classes
that I want to try like I really like
drawing so I'd want to get back into art
there's photography it could really
improve my photography skills like
illustration and graphic design as well
just there's just so many like classes
that just sound so interesting and fun I
think the opposite word there Nicha is
fun because learning is fun and
skillshare can help make learning fun so
thank you to today's sponsor skillshare
and the first 500 people to use my link
will get one month free trial of the
service and as a thank you to our
audience here's a little extra Bon bonus
fact for you guys did you know that
Steven Spielberg laughed at the Jaws
theme when he first heard it The Story
Goes that when Steven Spielberg
commissioned John Williams to create a
theme for Jaws he wanted to be more
swash bookling in nature because the
film ultimately it's a it's a film on
the sea like you know guys on a boat
hunting a big shark he wanted like a a
triumphant swashbuckling loud
extravagant theme when John Williams
came in and said I've got it Steve and
he went duh just two notes two notes on
a piano dunun dun dun dun and stepen
Spielberg burst out laughing and said
you can't be serious John no no trust me
and obviously this is John Williams
we're talking about so step Spiel said
okay I'll Trust you we'll put your theme
over like you know the shark scene see
how audiences react audiences screamed
so loud that you couldn't hear the film
and Steven Spielberg just looked at John
Williams said okay I trust you and they
put the theme in isn't that fun back to
the video actually no back back to you
car the first movie that famous players
lasi was supposed to film in London was
called the sorrow of Satan based on the
Marie Kelli novel so Hitchcock went home
and Drew a bunch of sketches that could
be used for title cards during the movie
this being the era of silent film title
cards were a pretty important part of
the film were often suggested of the
theme plots and were very intricately
decorated afterwards hitch went to the
studio and just started showing them to
people at random Hing someone anyone
would like them enough to give him a job
just one problem though the studio had
changed its mind and wasn't making that
film anymore instead it was going to
make a different movie called The Great
Day undaunted Hitchcock went back home
and did the exact same thing again this
time coming back with a bunch of title
CS that were altogether more uplifting
and inspiring and a bit lighter on the
whole Satan theme the next day he was
back at the studio and this time his
efforts did pay off that his ex liked
his work and his tenacity and hired the
20-year-old Hitchcock as a title card
designer and over the next few years
Hitchcock worked on all the movies that
famous players laski shot in London most
of them now lost forever from title car
designer he got promoted to art director
although he also dappled in script
writing and set design for anyone
curious about how he was able to do this
there were no unions back then so anyone
could do pretty much anything as long as
know they're asked to do it and have the
inclination to do so then in 1922 came
his big break Hitchcock was asked to
direct his first movie at least it was
supposed to be his big break and it's
quite fitting for the called master of
suspense that his first movie is
shrouded in a cloak of mystery as not
even the name of the movie he worked on
is quite certain if anyone curious
Hitchcock himself would later know that
the movie he worked on first was called
number 13 very mysterious but Studio
records say it was actually a movie
called Mrs Peabody the movie was never
finished and whatever bits were filmed
are lost forever so the Hollywood studi
British Excursion had been a financial
failure and it closed down its London
officers while Hitchcock was still
filming his directorial debut as a small
consolation prize Hitchcock did get a
chance the following year to finish
directing an independent British
production titled always tell your wife
after the original director left and as
a bigger consolation prize still
Hitchcock's skills experience and talent
were good enough that he immediately
found work with a trio of British
producers who were trying to get a new
film company off the ground and made him
the head of their title department like
before Hitchcock did a little bit of
this a little bit of that pretty much a
little bit of everything he wrote
screenplay about a movie titled woman to
woman and that ex ex liked it so much
they also appointed Hitchcock as the art
director and the ad for the picture more
importantly this was the movie where
Hitchcock met and fell in love with an
editor named Alma reveil they married in
1926 and stayed married until he died in
1980 the couple had one daughter named
Patricia together who had a few small
roles in her father's movies much in the
same way that he did but more on that
later in the video to top it all off
woman-on-woman was a success and help
found Gainesboro pitches Hitchcock's
status in the company grew steadily over
the next few years even traveling to
Germany to work on a few movies there
and gain some extra experience then in
1925 Hitchcock had the opportunity to
direct again a British German silent
drama titled the pleasure Garden this
was his true directorial debut and the
movie was well received enough that
Hitchcock was already being piled as one
of Britain's promising young directors
so unsurprisingly he got more directing
gigs after that he still worked as a
co-writer on many of his screenplays but
the title designing and art Direction
were left to somebody else somebody less
important the 1927 movie The lodger the
story of London Fog gave the world the
first taste of the Thrills and suspense
that would define Alfred Hitchcock's
lated career the movie essentially told
the tale of a Jack the Ripper style
serial killer who prayed on young
blondes at night it featured a land lady
who suspected her lodger of being the
murderer although he turned out to be
innocent he would later be reports that
Hitchcock would have preferred for the
guilt of the lodger to be left ambiguous
you know because that makes for an
altogether more interesting story but
since he was being played by Ivan aell
Gaines br's biggest mat Idol the studio
wanted to make it clear their star was
was not a villain Hitchcock will later
run into pretty much the exact same
problem a decade and a half later in
Hollywood with Carrie Grant in suspicion
despite this minor setback the lodic was
still a hit and it featured many
elements that would come to Define
Hitchcock as a filmmaker including his
first Cameo as an extra in the
background but more on that later the
next few years represented a series of
highs and some lows for the director
there were bright spots such as the ring
considered one of Hitchcock's best
silent movies and there were a few
stinkers such as champagne and the
farmer's wife his 1929 movie blackmail
is sometimes heralded as the first
British T well this isn't technically
true there was a poorly made
unsuccessful short called the clue of
the new PIN before it blackmail was the
movie that showed the British public
that sound had
[Music]
arrived during the 1930s Hitchcock
followed the success of blackmail with a
series of films that weren't quite so
memorable feeling the need for a change
the director moved to a new studio and
sign a contract with gourmont British in
19 1933 immediately this new pairing led
to much success with hitch's first movie
at g on The Man Who Knew Too Much
staring Peter laor not to confuse the
movie of the same name that Hitchcock
would make two decades later signed
James Stewart and Doris Day but his
second effort was even better a screen
adaptation of John buan spy Thriller
novel The 39th steps many fans and
critics would argue this was not only
the first true Hitchcock classic but
also the best film he made in Britain we
cannot get around the fact that Al
Alfred Hitchcock the director was
undeniably brilliant Alfred Hitchcock
the man was a prick to put it mildly his
behavior towards the people around him
could range from mild man and japery to
bullying and downright sadistic abuse
and we'll get on to his conduct towards
some of his blonde female stars
particularly TI hedrin a bit later but
for now let's focus on some of the
tricks he like to play on people so
Hitchcock had developed a reputation as
something of a prankster both on a set
and in his private life some of these
were relatively harmless like putting
whoopy cushions on people's chairs or
loudly telling an interesting anecdote
in a busy elevator and then leaving
right before the punch light the master
of suspense everybody but some of his
Antics straddled the border between
unacceptable and just like oh go on man
like throwing a dinner party where all
the food had been colored blue or
sending a live horse to the dressing
room of an actor but some of the stuff
Hitchcock did was abuse plain and simple
he was particularly cruel if you knew
you suffered from some kind of phobia
you could almost guarantee that he would
work it into some sort of prank which
was pretty sick and kind of hypocritical
coming from a guy with oop phobia the
fear of eggs yes the master of suspense
and a man who looked remarkably like an
egg was scared of eggs and perhaps the
meanest trick Hitchcock ever played on
someone that we're aware of is when a
crew member bet the director a week
salary that he would not be afraid to
spend a night alone in the dark Studio
chained to his camera at the end of the
day the handcuffs went on and Hitchcock
left with a key but not before getting
the man a nice bottle of brandy to keep
him warm throughout the night what the
crew member did not know though is that
Hitchcock had laced the Brandy with the
strongest LAX TI he could find which led
to shall we say predictable results the
next day they found the crew member
crying in a pool of without own
excrements and Hitchcock was laughing
uproariously at the sight when the poor
man was freed from his bondage and
shamefully shuffled off to the changing
rooms to clean himself Hitchcock did pay
the bit but told him never to mess with
him again but back to the movies the
second half of the decade saw Hitchcock
make five more films some of them were
good and some of them were n like
sabotage and Mal lady vanishes are both
regard as some of Hitchcock's best work
in Britain but his final film in the UK
for the time being a 1939 adaptation of
Daphne D Maria's Jamaica in was met with
a tepid reception then a new decade
dawned and so did a giant leap forward
for the career of Alfred Hitchcock as
Hollywood came a
calling so in 1939 hitchcott was lowed
by the glitz and glamour of Hollywood
plus you know a big fat check and a
water of cash and he moves to Los
Angeles where he signed a contract with
big shop producer David El snik who just
a few years prior had left MGM aside his
own independent Studio snik
International pictures so exactly when
that rols off the tongue but sure he had
money it wasn't around for long but it
lasted long enough to make Gone With the
Wind and firmly established sales was
one of the most important men in all of
Hollywood curiously even though
Hitchcock's previous film Jamaica in
didn't exactly set the Cinematic world
on fire for his first Hollywood project
the director chose another adaptation of
DNE dore's novel this time it was
Rebecca starring Lawrence Olivier and
Joe Fontaine he received a much better
reception to put it mildly by which we
mean it was nominated for 11 Oscars that
year including Hitchcock's first of five
nominations for Best Director and
Rebecca also won an Oscar for Best
Picture the only film in Hitchcock's
filmography to do so and just a little
bonus aside here it's not mentioned in
the script but it's still an interesting
tidbit about Hitchcock he holds the
joint record for shortest speech ever
made at the Oscars where he simply
walked onto the stage in 1968 when he
received an award of some kind looked at
the audience after they' finished
clapping and said thank you and then
walked off the stage I believe Carrie
Gran also did something similar a few
years prior moving on his follow-up
efforts were pretty good but and likely
to be included in Hitchcock's highlight
reel anytime soon the Spy Thriller
foreign correspondent and the comedy Mr
and Mrs Smith which yes is the same film
that was remade starring Angelina Jolie
and Brad Pit Hitchcock had another
problem because snik didn't really have
that much work for him to do his Studio
was still relatively small
and it only made a few films each year
so the producer loaned Hitchcock to
other companies such as Arko pictures
and 20th Century Fox and it was actually
RKO that the director made his next big
hit for suspicion reuniting him with
Joan Fontaine and representing the first
of four collaborations with Carrie Grant
as we mentioned earlier this was a rare
occasion where Grant played a Sinister
character but the studio was adamant
that he could not be the murderer even
though that was the case in the book the
movie was based on despite occasionally
butting heads with the studio XX the
1940s were a successful and productive
decade Hitchcock and there not a lot of
stinkers on his resume that decade under
Capricorn was probably the worst movie
like at least critically and the
Paradigm case received mixed reviews as
well but other than that the filmography
is looking pretty solid in 1942 hitch
made the Spy Thriller sabur which was
followed by the Classic Shadow of Doubt
in 1943 fun fact this was Hitchcock's
personal favorite movie and according to
his daughter this is because the
director loved the idea of taking a
quiet small town and injecting it with
some Menace his next two movies were
lifeb and Spellbound although nowadays
they don't immediately spring to mind
when you think of Hitchcock they both
gued him two more Oscar nominations for
Best Director they also featured
interesting collaborations for the
master of suspense Lifeboat was based on
a story written by John Steinbeck
specifically for the movie while
Spellbound included a dream sequence
designed by faint artist Salvador daring
in 1947 Hitchcock's contract with
sesnick ended and he founded his own
independent production company
transatlantic pitches to have more
control over his projects but this is
Hitchcock we talking about and he of
course ended his contract with a bank
the 1946 spy film Noir notorious
starring two of Hitchcock's favorite
actors ingri Bergman and Carrie Grant
again it was another Hitchcock classic
although Snick didn't really see it that
way first he wanted to replace Grant
with Joseph cotton because he was
cheaper they didn't like the idea of a
plot involving a Uranian bomb because he
thought it sounded like and I quote
science fiction this was a few months
before America dropped the atomic bomb
and Hiroshima and Nagasaki ultimately
Sals Nick became so uninterested that he
sold the whole production package like
script director actors and all do Arko
pictures out of nowhere Hitchcock did
not have a very good time with
transatlantic pictures in fact many
would argue it was the Nader his career
the production company only lasted for a
few years and made a handful of movies
that didn't really open to the kind of
critical or commercial reception that
was up to Hitchcock's reputation at the
time we should also mention that two of
those movies have received more
complimentary modern reassessment and
now regard as underrated Hitchcock
Classics one of them was strangers on a
train like my personal favorite
Hitchcock movie and I a of Patricia
heith debut novel and the other was rope
Hitchcock's first collaboration with
James Stewart he was also his first
color film well Hitchcock might have had
a few missteps at transatlantic But
ultimately it didn't matter because he
was about to enter the absolute peak of
his career that solidified Alfred
Hitchcock as one of the greatest
filmmakers in modern movie
history Hitchcock kicked off his
cinemagraphic zeni with his Grace Kelly
Trilogy three movies starring the future
princess of Monaco d m the murder To
Catch a Thief and last but certainly not
least Rio window all of them great films
especially the last one which is
frequently ranked one of the best movies
ever made around the same time the
director produced and hosted a
television Anthology series dubbed
Alfred Hitchcock Presents and it was a
big hit that went on for 10 years and
over
360 episodes but it also turned
Hitchcock himself into a celebrity and
at the time people saw directors as just
a name on a screen before a movie they
actually cared about started but with
his reton physique and dry witty sense
of humor and English accent just hitchko
cut a quite um interesting and novel
figure and as a result became quite
memorable and a household name the
director followed up rear window with
three more good but not great movies The
Trouble with Harry The Man Who Knew Too
Much and the wrong man they still made
for entertaining viewing but had The
Misfortune of Being SED between
Hitchcock's Grace Kelly Trio and the new
Trilogy that genuinely represents
perhaps the career performance of any
filmmaker ever so the year is 1958
followed by 1959 and 19 1960 that's
three years and in those three years
Hitchcock made three movies those movies
were vertigo North by Northwest and
psycho at the time like everyone knows
psycho right you say the term psycho
like like everybody knows psycho and I
would be remiss if I didn't at least
talk a little bit about the production
of psycho because it's genuinely
fascinating so psycho was like the
directorial followup to North by
Northwest it's huge bombastic color
movie and when Hitchcock pitched psycho
the studio Studio were not impressed by
it at all and they were very very keen
to get Hitchcock to do something else so
much so that Hitchcock basically had to
underbid himself so first he agreed like
to not take his usual directorial fee
and they were like no it's still too
much money then he told him okay so I
won't use a film crew I'll use the crew
from my TV show that that'll be cheaper
right and so now it's still too
expensive okay I'll make it in black and
white and says okay black and white film
is cheaper and then when he was making
psycho um he basically invented what we
would understand today to be viral
marketing um by engaging in a series of
like publicity stunts to like just hide
what the ending of the movie was
starting with buying as many copies of
the novel the film was based on as
possible and then publicizing that fact
and went as why I don't want anyone to
know the ending then he released a
series of trailers that rather than
showing the movie itself simply had him
walk out into frame and tell people that
if they didn't turn up to the movie on
time the doors would be closed and they
will be unable to attend that screening
obviously once you've reached the top
there's nowhere really to go but down
although admittedly it was a gentle slow
for Hitchcock his next movie was the
birds which while not well received when
it came out it standing has improved
somewhat with time and it's widely
considered one of Hitchcock's best and
most memorable works but the most
disturbing aspect of the production
though was the director's weird
obsessive relationship with the leading
lady Tippi hedrin and this would report
to continue into the production of their
next film together man and it's worth
noting after Hitchcock's death Tippy
hedrin would accuse him of being cruel
and abusive to her in person and
sexually assaulting her in private when
she reported his aters so even threaten
to ruin her career it's undoubtedly a
darker chapter in Hitchcock's life that
often Spurs that age- old debate whether
or not you should separate art from
artist so bring it back to the art
Hitchcock was entering the Twilight of
his career he'd been a prolific director
shooting on average one film a year
since 1925 however he was getting old
and had never exactly been at the peak
of physical health however his wife Alma
was in even worse condition having been
left partially paralyzed following two
strokes and Hitchcock didn't really want
to leave her alone for extended periods
of time between 1966 and 1976 he only
made four films Tor curtain topaz frenzy
and family plot most reviews are mixed
with the occasional praise especially
for frenzy which hitot got to film back
in his native London in his later years
the director's Health seriously declined
but he got to enjoy one last honor
before passing away in January 1980 he
was given a night Hood by Queen
Elizabeth II although was too ill to
travel to England to receive it
Hitchcock died just a few months later
on April 29th age 80 leaving behind a
tricky Legacy to Define if you look at
it solely based on his filmography then
you are undoubtedly looking at one of
the greatest filmmakers who has ever
lived however if you take into account
Alfred Hitchcock with the person I
remember all the stories of abuse on and
offet then Hitchcock becomes a flawed
even sadistic figure who was really
really good when he sat in the
director's chair and a pretty terrible
person when he was out of
it as is often the case with many
figures throughout history so I hope
everyone at home enjoyed this video and
found it entertaining informative and
educational I certainly found the script
to be all three of those things and
encourage everyone at home to follow the
author R Alexander on the socials link
below you can follow me if you feel like
it but I don't really post all that much
I also have my own channel fact them
with Kyle Smallwood and contribute to
Wiki weekend with my friend Lucas if you
enjoyed the video leave a like if you
got anything to say or some feedback
suggestions for other figures to cover
maybe some other stories from
Hitchcock's career we didn't cover here
or trivia about his movies we' be
excited to hear them and can respond to
them in the comments below or maybe pin
one to the top I don't know I don't run
that part of the channel but I'm always
excited to read trivia about movies you
can't tell it's a personal passion of
mine otherwise I hope everyone out there
has a great day and as always no I hope
everybody out there enjoyed the video
and as I always like to say have the day
you all deserve
[Music]
cheers